where did you grow up I grew up in New
Britain Connecticut
two hours north of New York City so what
was your upbringing like
great parents were together the whole
time stable I had a sister brother
um so I mean they're still alive now I
haven't said had yeah like they're gone
yeah
um yeah I mean I grew up I went to high
school played basketball in high school
played video games had still had my
childhood friends to this day I would
say I grew up like in a pretty good
situation we didn't grow up with money
right we grew up fairly you know poor
little you know lower middle class my
parents struggled especially in the
beginning yeah I mean I wouldn't trade
it for the world I think it's important
for young men to grow up like struggling
yeah
you know what's interesting my family
was always like the had the most money
but we spent it like we were very frugal
growing up I mean we always had a big
house I'm gonna say that we always
always had a big house but when it came
to like
um I don't know clothes like we always
had hand-me-downs we never flew on
vacation we drove we didn't have cable
TV and I just feel like you shouldn't
spoil children sometimes in the red pill
they'll be like spoil the women they
shouldn't have hard stuff either and I'm
like ah I don't know then you kind of
get a little spoiled brat I think it's
you it builds character you have to do
it how will you raise a son with your
mindset I'm just curious tonight uh I
would raise my son to not be a victim uh
you know I'm at a point now where a very
successful financially but my son would
not see any of this money at all I would
make him get it out the mud because
um like we discussed before trust fund
babies typically don't know what to do
in life and how to you know they don't
understand and appreciate the value of a
dollar and I thank my dad for instilling
in that man that in me early I mean my
first job was at McDonald's and I got
fired and I quickly learned that I
didn't want to be in the service
industry but it made me appreciate
people in the service industry so I
cannot imagine
what is this by the way this is like a
tonic wine when I drink I'm like quite a
mellow person chill completely in the
mood you're not an angry drunk no I'm
not actually no okay that's good I'd be
the worst angry oh Auntie Jenny is
calling me
I said Auntie Jenny is calling me I'll
call her back
um
oh yeah
um hey Auntie
hi
what um what did you call what's up
no I was just watching your shirt
about being frugal
and I think a lot of women don't want to
be frugal
no it's true
the way that you're just because they've
got the money they I think they
explained it they did it you know it
doesn't mean you have to spend it
stupidly
I mean we always thought you said if you
got kids they always pass the clothes
down so it's normally the oldest that
gets new clothes unless you're going out
yeah I was lucky I was the oldest girl
you know we always used to go the
cheapest way and take apart lunch have a
picnic on the way
and I think if I if I had money I'll
still do the same thing I think that's
how come I'm so Frugal because I learned
from my mom
had to be frugal and then you need to
spend money on the important things
if you're if you're free you can come
watch it with me
[Music]
yeah
you're right you're just a bit far
no because I know that you're alive
aren't you you're alive yeah yeah of
course
your daddy I'm laughing your dad's right
I think it's better to marry
married none because when you struggle
together with your mentality if you
believe in your man you've helped him
build up his business and I think when
couples struggle and suffer together if
they're meant to be together it just
makes them stronger and they learn to
appreciate more than more that they've
got so I think the reason why your
family was so Frugal because they know
how they got that money they didn't just
make it overnight they weren't bloodyard
and sacrifice for it whereas if you meet
a man he's already made it what are you
gonna do is friends
mm-hmm
no no there's nothing to work towards I
think that yeah couples that fight
together and do all things like that I
think that they they're the ones that
last
so I'd go with the poor man but I know a
lot of women will go with a rich man but
I'm with your dad on that
well my dad always talks about like if
it's a big age Gap you're not going to
be alive for the last half of your life
and I feel like there's I was like I
never understood on you yeah yeah that's
what my dad was saying so yeah never
thought of that
adult nappies
huh
that's what you need to think about I
took them you choose really really old
they eventually you're gonna have to
start cleaning it
never thought about that yeah I mean I
don't know anyone with an age Gap that's
lasted like long term but I'm not saying
they can't I've just never the only
people I know it's like only been a
couple years so it's kind of too soon to
say
so why would she try to sabotage her
friend yeah because Andy knows but I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna finish this
video you're welcome to come by so I
just felt that I'm joining because your
dad was on our vote yet I'm your dad
you're a dad okay
all right bye
I love Auntie Jenny not drink
I don't Haram see you have you never
drunk I have I definitely have but I
mean it's not really conducive to my
life goals at the moment so I don't
really drink like that it's just myself
one isn't it yeah I mean I stopped
drinking too fun fact man you you can't
afford to have things that clout your
you know your inhibition or your ability
to go out there and create and become a
better version of yourself and I think
like that's why I'm really big on like
not drinking doing drugs any of that
stuff you got to be focused all the time
so how do you find dating then with the
way that you are I mean when you
understand uh the code it's you know
Plug and Play it's like okay just deal
with the girl size her up figure out
what kind of trick she is and then bam
you know you already know kind of how to
how to move so like what's the code
depends on I wonder how I would be sized
up
and please chat don't say nobody's
trying to size you up anyway all right
all right I'm not everyone's cup of tea
but if I was I just want to know what
I'd be sized up
because I just can't imagine any girls
like gonna want to be like hug me at the
beginning of the day
okay you got to be able to adapt based
on the woman that you're sitting across
the table from yeah I have the female
codes in my sleeves I know pretty much
worth what they all are okay so how are
you adapting to me right now you want me
to be honest yeah yeah close Okay I want
the code now and then I'll ask the code
again by the end of it yeah I would say
uh recreational use only no offense so
what's like the old how many codes is
there well it depends on the Mercury wow
wow nope
you know if you deal with a girl that's
younger that's in her prime years well
you got to understand that she's more
you know inclined to look for fun if
you're dealing with a girl that is in
her mid-20s a lot of times as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible